I have a lot of respect for the your
mom's house Network I think it's a great
network I think Tom and Christina are
very funny dr. Drew who's also on the
network is very talented at what he does
and I've never listened to his show but
I like Celebrity Rehab and I enjoyed
Loveline with Adam Kroll and dr. Dre
they're good people and that's fine I
want to preface this by saying my first
instinct is always to lie and it is
always the right instinct for the most
part lying shows that you've taken a
time to think about what's happening and
that you care about what's happening
telling the truth is like not wearing
deodorant it's inconsiderate and it
means that you don't care it means you
don't have any regiment you haven't
thought about anything you've kind of
just rolled out of bed
that's why truth when you're honest with
somebody there's a premium to that it's
usually with somebody you really like a
friend somebody you're [ __ ] it
there's a premium to honesty because
it's rare honesty is not something that
happens all the time for good reason
people just don't walk around being
honest with each other the world would
be in utter chaos if everybody told
everybody what they thought of each
other it would be an utter cat people
have to be kept in the dark they have to
be lied to and manipulated this is why
we have what we have with the Epstein
and the da da da okay I'm just saying
how it is
I'm not saying how it should be I'm not
moralizing I'm telling you what it is
people keep secrets no conspiracies
aren't real cuz no one can keep seeing
you're keepin secrets right now from
your wife and you're telling me that no
one can keep secrets you're keeping
secrets with somebody asleep next to
secrets can kept for [ __ ] years
people have secret families they never
talk about there's good lawyers out
there you know this says nobody can keep
secrets bad Liars bad Liars can never
believe in conspiracies because they
don't know how to [ __ ] lie they don't
know how to create create and craft a
narrative lies you can't just [ __ ]
around with a lie here and there you got
to be constantly lying all the time you
got to create a world and populate it
with untruths
big lies require little eyes to sustain
them that's a famous quote I don't know
who said it that's what needs to happen
pathological lies lie all the time
because they want to be good at it if
you drunk if you drink and drive every
night statistically you're going to be
better at it am i telling you to do it
no I'm telling you what it is if you
drink a drive once a month you're gonna
be all nervous same with driving high
same with lying same with [ __ ] same
with stand-up comedy you got to do it a
lot ok so my first instinct in many
situations is to spin a yarn a fable a
lie an untruth because I care about the
person on the other end I realize that
I've done the wrong thing and rather
than admit it like a crazy person I lie
to cover it up
because I realize I was wrong you're
lying because you realize you're wrong
if anyone calls you what a lie say I'm
lying to you because I know that I'm
wrong and I love you being honest with
you would be insane am i insane are you
insane honesty is not the best policy no
one says that you know who says that
schoolteachers because they talked to
children all day because they have
childlike minds we don't need any advice
that's on a guidance counselors wall
it's not going to help
don't hit me about no Walter no lie even
after today I will still lie I'm only
upset at the fact that my lie was not
good never lie quick take a minute take
a breath today big Jays girlfriend
Christine Evans who I like but you know
we'll get into that you know you know
these people you know I just you know
I her butt and she's in town she grew up
in Redondo Beach uh and she goes hey I
want to show you where I grew up we'll
go to the beach take a little swim we'll
get sassy food and a seafood shack I'm
in I like swimming in the ocean I'm in
there we did we had a beautiful lunch
but a half-hour lunch about a 45 minute
dip in the Pacific Ocean
and to do all that round trip in a car
about five and a half hours in the car a
five and a half in the car I could have
driven I could have flown to New York
City for the amount of time it took me
to get my fat ass in the Pacific for
forty five [ __ ] minutes but it was a
lovely dip and I like that it's just
it's it's a lot traveling around LA is a
lot she tells me all what you want to
put on some music so I put on some music
i put on Toby Keith's song God love her
it's a great song God love uh she was
born in a Mississippian Mont I don't
know the [ __ ] lyrics her daddy didn't
want her to be with me and I said you
know who cares it's catchy
it was unshut 'full I put it on she's
like oh you have the worst dates music
and of all of my friends I'm like [ __ ]
Toby keeps you talking all day about how
she wanted to buy all the houses in
Manhattan Beach she's like I want to buy
these houses
I keep telling Jay for millions not a
lot of money we're an entertainment for
men [ __ ] Toby Keith could buy ten of
those houses and you're running your
mouth I said that tour the car go Toby
Keith quite ten of these houses
you'll die in this rental you don't have
to agree with Toby key you know if they
think he's good that's a catchy goddamn
song God love her so we get down there
we have a nice of a nice lunch I do this
Instagram story where I'm on the beach
we go up this beautiful peak in Redondo
we're looking out at the ocean it's got
a great view when I say hey I write on
Instagram I say hey cuz these are you so
you will see things that are similar to
this you know six months ago I was
living in the mid
of a busy highway but I started reading
listening to gary vay-ner-chuk and he's
the teachings of gary van your truck and
now I realized when I heard him that I
had to stop losing and I had to start
winning and now we just broke ground on
what'll be a twenty five million dollar
state and how did I pay for it I paid
for it with gratitude and then you know
hashtag hustle grind
it's a funny post and it clearly shows
that I'm in Redondo Beach the beautiful
then she goes as a Trump golf course
it's open to the public you want to go
check that out I'm like oh yeah I think
it's fun go see what kinds of people are
still going to trump things who don't
give a [ __ ] I kind of like that you know
and it's just a bunch of white dudes and
dads and they're all playing golf and
you know me and her walk in and you know
they're not thrilled but she's like it's
open to the public and I felt like
explaining to her honey not our public
see the Palos Verdes public is different
than our public our public is public bus
it's not open to us okay I guarantee you
I'm wearing a bathing suit and you're
wearing a sarong you bought on the
Venice Boardwalk from somebody with a
heroin needle hanging out of their chin
so that's not the public that they're
really interested in walking through
their doors okay but I didn't by the way
they I mean Venice it's like you go down
there the best things there are the
bodybuilders with AIDS Muscle Beach all
the bodybuilders with AIDS is like
beating AIDS they all have AIDS and
they've beaten AIDS they're so built
they no longer have AIDS or penises like
you know their penises have gone away
because they've just pumped so much iron
and they've all beaten AIDS but I didn't
see them today because the outdoor gym
was being remodeled sadly so we go to
the Trump course she goes
the bathroom to change your clothes like
a true crackhead okay
she's like well she has some fake
question about the restaurant she's like
what is the restaurant open where's the
restroom I'm like they know what you're
in here for they know you just want to
go in there deliver a baby and leave it
in the toilet
so just go do that and I'll go take a
[ __ ] and then we'll leave okay we don't
have to pretend that we're here to talk
to the event planner about throwing a
wedding okay they know you just want to
abandon a baby in the bathroom so almond
do you ever see somebody when you like
walk into a nice place and you start
telling the tale about while you're
there and the people like we know what
this is just [ __ ] we're letting you do
it just use the restroom you don't have
to it when's teton just use the just go
throw up
you're withdrawing right you're
withdrawing and you you need to throw up
before you get some suboxone okay just
go do that don't [ __ ] tell us that
yeah you're here to plan your daughter's
wedding so I I remember I don't remember
I get an email from the book of the your
mom's house Network email was 408 said
hey Tim I hope you're finding your way
here
hope you're having no trouble finding
the place text me well I experience a
range of emotions in the Trump bathroom
in Palos Verdes I was like [ __ ] I was
supposed to do dr. drew today at 4:00
[ __ ] it is now 458 that email was sent
to me at four away I'm in the Trump
bathroom
I did what I never used to do I used to
call out sick from work all the time but
I never did the no call no show which
was what I did now now here's when you
do the no call no show you have to
off the grid and you have to not fire
back you need to get your story straight
you need to sit on it for a minute and
think because you've done the no call no
show the only ways to go harder into the
light disappear off the grid sink deeper
into the hole take a minute think about
it go what can I do here you know go
grab an old photo of you in New York
throw that on Instagram go dark for two
days email the dude say you had to go be
in New York who knows all these things
but I panicked
I was panic-stricken I'm so ashamed of
this
I was panic-stricken on the toilet in
the Trump golf course open to the public
Palos Verdes beautiful I was sitting on
the toilet reading the email on the
turlet and I said [ __ ] I email back
immediately
I had an emergency I cannot make it it
by the way it's a [ __ ] hour after I
supposed to be there I emailed two
seconds later I apologize I walk out I'd
call Ben and then it hits me I uploaded
an Instagram story from the beach a
half-hour ago when I should have been
doing the show I have a photo up from
the [ __ ] beach which is the opposite
of an emergency it is literally the
opposite of an emergency I am frolicking
on the beach and I didn't show up for
this [ __ ] show and then I lied to the
guy and it was such a poorly conceived
lie like it was shut and now I'm ashamed
not because I lied because I didn't put
the time in the care into a good lie
nothing makes you feel better than
pulling off a good lie and I didn't do
it and I pride myself on being able to
do it and I was just and the thing that
saves me is it's so funny
that there's something there there's
something I was so funny that I couldn't
stop laughing because it's so utterly
disrespectful it's so utterly
disrespectful
it's [ __ ] amateur hour it's it's
gizelle just lanes are it's just laying
eating in and out
reading spy novels it's choking epstein
out in his cell and then [ __ ] like it's
all that [ __ ] on a very small level it's
it's I'm doing to the book or that
Network what our government is doing us
basically going oh [ __ ] you and I hope
you like it I hope you like it because
it is what it is and here's a photo of
me with my [ __ ] fat ass frolicking on
the beach and I had an emergency and I
can't make it I email you an hour after
I was supposed to be there so I would
imagine at this point I would not be
shocked there's a lot of opportunities
and you go why didn't I get that
opportunity there's a lot of opportunity
here's the silver lining to this I will
not wonder if I'm never on any of their
shows I won't lie it won't keep me awake
at night
like I might forget this and think for a
minute I wonder why and then I go oh
yeah oh yeah yeah there was that time I
know called no-showed for dr. drew after
dark and then shot often amateur hour
email from the turlet of the Trump and
then right on the Instagram story it's
like it's not only like I'm lying to you
it's really like I should it would have
almost be better if I'd emailed them
back hey [ __ ] you
that would have almost been better if I
went hey how about [ __ ] you cuz that's
what it is saying you at an emergency
and then having the Instagram story of
you at the beach is two words
[ __ ] you it is that I didn't even take
the time to lie good about this I just
thought I would [ __ ] throw it out
there
so if you message me some of you message
me you go you should do your mom's house
and I go yeah yeah I'd love to do that
show they're great you don't have to
message that anymore I'd still like to
do it but if I don't do it this one is
100% on me this is my fault this is a
bad move
[ __ ] Thank You Christine Evans
ruining my [ __ ] life I'm gonna
refresh my email let's see if the guy
from the Booker from your mom's house
has not gotten back to me I gotta think
that's a bad sign now I don't know I've
been your producer of a podcast you you
you and habit this world now how do you
how do you think this person feels I'm
gonna get a cigarette how do you think
this person feels about what happened
today
[ __ ] you were an hour late you didn't
respond for a whole hour
they were definitely checking your
Instagram and they saw the post for sure
and they thought oh [ __ ] this guy
absolutely [ __ ] this guy you get the
matches yeah yes Ben I believe that all
to be the case but as somebody who's a
do you do you say how do you do you
laugh about it do you say Tim is a funny
guy he's a funny guy and he's a wacky
guy do you maybe bring me in to berate
me and have Drew berate me for being a
liar is that not nice I bet that would
be hilarious but I bet dr. Drew's
probably a guy that his time is very
valuable so who knows who did you see
who they pulled in by the way did they
pull in somebody who I didn't look I
don't think they're recording live cuz
Jessa Reed
did one and hers is gonna come out later
on I bet Drew was pissed I bet he was
mad cuz he's sitting there he drove all
the way up to what Reseda it's sent in
traffic to [ __ ] I can't control where
people go Ben
K I can't control where people go I told
you I had a [ __ ] emergency my mother
got out of her institution and wound up
in Manhattan Beach now I was shocked
when the people of my mother's mental
institution caught me go your mother is
on the run again I said how far did she
get out back they said no she's been
sighted in Manhattan Beach by the tenth
Street Beach which is beautiful
you should go and try to find her in the
water and then when I got to the tenth
Street Beach they said I think she's at
captain trips fish market why don't you
go there and if she's not there at least
try the black and salmon and the lobster
roll and the macaroni salad which were
phenomenal and then I got the captain
shrimp sent they go she might be at the
Trump golf course so this [ __ ] I'm
trying to get her with a big match she's
a big woman
now it's an emergency
god I am so [ __ ] bad I am so banned
there never had
me back I never had me back I am done I
am so done